[Music]
hello and welcome to
grand master's choice i am grand master
dennis borosch
and this is going to be about the french
now some love the french some hate it
and some
completely despise it there was someone
who didn't quite respect it
too much and his name was saviali
tartakover
yes he is not even in the 20th century i
mean he is in the 20th century
but not in the 21st he was playing chess
in the 1930s and 40s
and played as magnificent players as
frank marshall and mr
fine ruben fine so without any further
ado
let's see what tartakover has as a
secret recipe
against the french defense the first
game
is between rudolph spellman who was a
very aggressive tactical player
himself e4
e6 b4 d5
now there's a gazillion moves in this
type of position
i can go e5 and just cram down black's
position
go knight c3 just to retain
the pressure with knight c3 or knight d2
i think there's also this weird little
move of queen d3 but obviously that
would
waste a lot of time takes queen takes
at f6 queen h4 and even though
white still has an extra pawn in the
center
this queen is offsides and
there's still lots of pieces to develop
anyways
tartakover went for bishop d3 a move
that had
kind of a surge of popularity recently
but
isn't anything accurate or
poisonous so bishop d3 is the move
what tartakover played however
it was mostly there to put rudolph
spillman
off and probably wrong foot him
bishop d3 c5 c3
now nowadays people say oh the french is
great the french is wonderful
oh there's a french lecture there french
lecture over there
whoa more french lectures and that's all
good
you know the more material you have the
better
but facts are facts and chess is an
objective game
this dude on c8 ain't happy
and it's not going to be happy for a
while
that's why people actually switched from
e4
e6 to e4 c6
d4 d5 e5
and bishop f5 this system is the karakan
and the reason they play it is because
they have a good bishop
compared to that terrible bishop that
you can see in this position
now even if you think about that
tartakover
actually played somewhat dubious of the
moves
getting the bishop out early you're
supposed to get the knight
out first and not the bishop and then he
is
deliberately going for an isolated pawn
normally
these would be sins that could be just
punished
and be normal however if let's say you
take
take a d e takes knight f6
bishop f3 you have a tough time
punishing this because a this bishop is
a monster
b this bishop on c8 is yet to be able to
develop
note it also can go to d7 because the b7
pawn is hanging
i'm not claiming that white has an
advantage and probably
does not but it kind of shows
the downside of this whole system the
french defense as it is
has this problem with this bishop and if
you can't solve that problem
you might just well run into
big issues knight c6 not f3
and this is again inviting
rudolph's spellman for a tango he's
saying hey
go ahead exchange pawns create an
isolated pawn for me
you are still way behind in development
so it will
not give you an advantage like b4
could actually make some sense now if
bishop b5 bishop d7
this would happen this actually would be
a dream scenario for black
finally you've got rid of the famous
french bishop
and then after e5 you might even have
a dangerous initiative because you take
away
the castling rights and knight d3 is
incoming this would be a beautiful
position
but obviously white is not forced to do
that
and instead probably should just give up
the
bishop on d3 takes
takes d e and both queen e4 and knight
e4 is fine
you could even consider it takes here
queen h4
and again here comes the same dilemma
black has
very good i mean has the bishop bear
those bishops aren't too active yet
so i don't think they're that good just
yet
however if they get
activated black will have a better
position
due to this weak pawn on d4
but even in that case white is not lost
or not even slightly worse
which shows that this whole system is a
little bit dodgy to say the least
knight f6 was played instead
sorry about that knight f6 was played
e5 knight d7 and in this position
we are actually transposing back
to a classical tarash position
knight d2 would be a straight
transposition
to these tarash lines that knight d2
where they often play cd cd and
f6 leading to the main line
but tartakover uses this extra
opportunity
to castle and he doesn't have to waste
time getting the knight to d2
what is the benefit of castling here
instead of playing knight d2
knight d2 is a nice thematic move
but it does block the view of this
bishop
so he will not have those extra
ideas that he will have in the game just
a little bit of a hint right there
queen v6 and here
white is at crossroads
black puts lots of pressure on d4
and white will have to decide whether
it's time to give it up
or
just to exchange it
the question is dear viewer which one
would you choose
for some of you who are more familiar
with knight d2 systems you might be
eager to play knight d2
by the way bishop e3 is not a move
because you run into queen takes b2 and
not only do you lose a very important
core pawn on b2
you might as well lose the center pawns
one by one because f9 d2 queen takes
c3 and not only did black win another
pawn but the bishop is under attack
and black is just much better
so bishop e3 is never an option in these
type of positions
but knight d2 is transposing back into
these lines
c takes c takes knight takes d4
takes takes knight f3
and i've seen queen b6 and queen g4
being played
b4 here but queen b6 is completely fine
as well
and in this specific case black is up
upon but all of these pieces on
ca d7 and f8 are jumbled up and they
don't really have
an easy way to get developed so here
bishop f4
is a typical idea so let's say bishop b7
bishop f4
castles rook c1 and
blank is still struggling to actually
finish
development knight c5 often runs into
bishop e3
to it's not that simple to get bishop d7
in you might as well run into ideas of
bishop c5 bishop c5 and bishop h7
the typical greek sacrifice so something
like
takes takes takes on h7 knight g5
even queen c2 if someone is not that
adventurous
you could go this way and just pick back
pick the pawn back
or knight g5 and queen h5
so even knight d2 in this position is
completely
acceptable for white and this leads to
good compensation
not an advantage but definitely a
position that white can't
play for a win in any case here
tartakover chose
d takes c5 pinpointing the fact that
this bishop on c1 had not moved yet
and also there's no knight blocking its
view
so bishop c5 queen e2 again
there's two core concepts in this
position you want to over defend the e5
pawn and the f2 pawn
if any of them becomes a target you will
have
a tough time between c7 and the key move
bishop f4 now white has
this extra move that you normally don't
have
in any systems whenever your knight is
on d2
because it's stuck on c1 and you
physically can't move
to f4 so
with this extra move in the idea of
tartar cover playing
three bishop d3 comes alive and
now it's just very problematic for black
as there's no clear counter play just
yet
or at least i cannot find any f6 which
would be a thematic idea
known in the french fails
to he takes f6 and the king will be
in danger
so let f6 takes takes queen takes
king d8 oh fg and the pawn promotes
and if there's no f6 there's no clear
way
for black to try to get the initiative
himself
it goes bishop e7 trying to untangle
the bishop e7 knight c5
however when your opponent
is starting to play slower moves
and decide not to castle you've got to
think about
options of punishing your opponent
for this misbehavior
let's think about that a little bit
so f6 doesn't really work we don't have
to fear that
at all now
logically you could think about knight
d2 just connecting
drugs and there's nothing wrong with
that
however when we think about punishing
moves such as bishop e7 queen c7 we're
thinking about moves
that will take away even more space from
our opponent
or push them even further back
so here the move that was played by
tartakover was none other than
c4 and for the initiated
this looks strange why did you play c3
and then suddenly play
c4 that doesn't make any sense well the
circumstances have
changed a lot in this position
you want to keep this connect4 alive
therefore you played c3 knight f3 and
made sure that this pawn is defended
but then you shift it gears took the
pawn
takes queen e2 bishop f4 bishop e7
and suddenly there came an opportunity
to attack the black king now it's a
solid
closed position so from a strategical
point of view the french is
sound the pawn structure is quite nice
and it
does give a sturdy structure however
because of that the bishop on c8 is
closed in
now c4 doesn't help
the role of that bishop it's still
closed in it can't really move
but after c4 now you have this very very
good square for the knight on c3
and now there'll be some pressure on d5
it's knight b4 immediately spillman
is going for some counter chances on the
other side of the board
hoping to muster up some play or at
least win a pawn
as a form of compensation
knight b4 now if you would take bishop
takes c4
castles knight c3 this would be
quite terrible for black because there's
at least
one two and three moves to make till
black
actually completes full development
while white might just hop into d6
kind of making black's life miserable
so c4 was played at b4 trying to attack
this bishop and targeting that pawn
on c4 now depending
on your style you would choose your next
move
some might play knight c3 the likes
of shirov or mihal tal would play knight
c3 here
saying the devil may care i'm giving up
the pawn
and if you take it you open up
files so let's say queen c4 queen d2
your queen is misplaced and it might
actually come
under fire after rook c1 and if d takes
c4
i draw back and i can go knight e4
knight d6
the same plan be mentioned before or
alternatively knight b5
knight d6 hitting the queen and then
locating the knight that juicy square
however tartakover said i have a better
position
there is no reason for me to take
extra risks or at least not yet so we
played knight d2 instead
knight d3 queen takes d3 knight b6
so some of you might exclaim that hey
black does have the bishop
bear why doesn't that count for a whole
lot
in this position and i can tell you why
this position
ain't that good because it's a closed
position
bishops need open lines and open files
to actually be useful not here
not in this position they're rather
useless because they don't really have
any targets yet
and it will require two more moves
for black to actually fix his
development
not to mention that he didn't castle
either
rook c1 very strong move
immediately saying that i know you
haven't developed at
all so it's time for me to go all out
with the attack d takes c4 i take c4
here black doesn't really have a choice
you'd love to put the knight on d5
but in that case there's knight d6 check
and you're losing the queen
so black is obliged to take who could
take c4
queen a5 and again here comes
the big question time
black is still a couple of moves away
from
completing development a couple of moves
away from playing bishop d7 bishop c6 or
castles so we've got to figure out a way
to continue with the attack
so i'll give you guys a little bit of
time to think about the next move
so whenever we are looking at these
positions
we first identify what our opponent's
goals are
and also what defenders we have to
remove
to kind of weaken their position
and if you realize which piece is the
strongest defender
in black's position tatakova's next move
isn't that hard but it's still
quite a nice idea by
dr tartakover
so one of the ideas would be to go
bishop g5
trying to exchange however it would be
costly it will
it would cost you a pawn
g5 queen takes c5 and not that this
isn't an interesting option you could
even consider
going f4 and going for an attack here
now queen f6 would be a bad mistake
because there's knight e4 and
knight d6 going all out with the attack
probably would be decisive
but tartakover felt that there's no need
to go for bishop g5 immediately
and give up a pawn
he decided to go bishop d2 now bishop d2
also gives up a pawn
but there is a quality difference
between the e5 pawn and the a21
the e5 pawn makes sure this bishop on c8
cannot breathe
and that is much more important
than that pawn on a2 which actually does
absolutely nothing for white
and if it's there or not there doesn't
really matter for mr
tartakover queen takes a2 rook c1
immediately going for the attack
bishop d7
and black might have thought hey i'm
only a single move away
from completing my development and i'm
gonna have
a beautiful beautiful time over here
get the bishop on c6 i castle i'm up
upon
i will be winning this game
but tartakover said no no no i'm going
to go rook c7
and that rook on the 7th is going to
wreck some havoc over there
bishop c6 there's some nice little
tactics
that white has
namely rook takes c6 b takes
and queen d7 and the queen will
go gobble town on all of those pieces
and pawns
until it is checkmate
so bishop c6 is a no-go you can't quite
play there because i take and queen d7
so black had to go rook d-8
and i'm pretty sure as spellman was a
very strong player
he calculated this far and said hey
it's a fine deal if you would
take anything i will have this covered
attack with my rook
so what is the problem in this position
hint hint there are some problems in
this position
so he actually said hey i don't see the
problem with taking on b7
probably in his calculations spillman
thought that hey
if you do that i go bishop c6
and with your rook hanging and your
queen
under attack it's a double attack so
you'll be in trouble by the way a side
note
black cannot just castle because you
lose the bishop on d7
takes takes queen takes d7 and byte is
just up a whole piece so at this moment
spillman was forced to enter this line
of bishop c6
and attacking but i'm quite sure that
spillman was happy at this moment saying
hey okay you're forcing me to win the
exchange
be my guest however
the rude awakening is about to come
boom rook takes c7 king takes e7
and by in itself this wouldn't be an
issue for
spillman you can't win the bishop your
queen is
under attack on d3 however there's this
check on g5
black moss block but that's as you can
tell
never a good sign if you have to play f6
and it's not for the reason of
undermining
probably you're doing something wrong
and in this case it's not nothing
different
y takes on f6 gf bishop
f6 which is a very nice little touch
king takes
queen c3 king e7
problem is the king rook
are not too well coordinated especially
that queen on a2 is far
far away from the action not where it's
supposed to be
so king e7 is played and
here white plays this very nice little
intermezzo queen c5
check and seemingly all
is fine after rook d6
spielman thought that i i defend the
bishop i'm up a whole rook
what can really go wrong but after queen
g5 check
surprisingly enough it's difficult to
coordinate all these guys if you go king
f7
you run into knight e5 ideas and if you
go king f8
then i just go queen e5 and suddenly you
can't
defend the rook on h8 or d6
something similar happened in the game
spellman played king e8
queen e5 double attacking
rook g8 queen takes d6 bishop f3
and it looks really good from afar
but with this queen so far away it's
clear that this is going to be checkmate
rook ca check was played king f7 queen
f3 and the end of the day
after king g
7 you run into queen g5
and i'm going to capture everything with
the check
and it's game over very nice game
by tartakover he went for
a sub-line of the french variation not
necessarily
the best line but something that is
practically
challenging don't forget this was played
in 1913
like in 1913 and for that
this was quite a high quality game
so let's take a look at another
tartakover
game that was really well played by him
this one is played between emmanuel
alaska
and tartakover
so e4 e6 d4 d5
knight c3 at f6 and the big rage
of our times is e5 knight d7
f4 c5 and knight f3
knight c6 bishop e3
again i've seen many players play bishop
e3 early
but there is a simple rule to follow
whenever you're studying openings
always develop your knights first and
get the bishop
next you can go wrong in that case
so knight f3 knight c6 and bishop e3
this is the main line currently
and is hotly debated
now this became like really the hot
topic once kramnik started playing one
e4 and he suddenly beat it for jabba
in this opening but in the 1920s
30s bishop g5 was the main line
championed by none other than the great
french
russian grand master alyohin
or alakine whichever way you want to
pronounce his name
bishop e7 e5 knight d7
a solid system very
very solid way of playing black is
trying to undermine white's position
later on with c5
however alejin had a
favorite patented line here
and it is h4
the whole point is i am willing to give
up the pawn but for that
you are going to give me an active rook
and eventually after some night
slaloming
i might have some targets on g7
so lasker as a gentleman as he was
he took the pawn takes six knight h3
queen h6 now queen h6 is not the move
that i would love
too much because yes it stops this
rook from exerting direct pressure on
against the king's side however the
queen is misplaced
for little to no good reason
but if you go queen e7 y can go knight
f4 and you would face this knight's
slalom
which is kind of annoying provoking some
extra weaknesses
on the king side so
if you're not really familiar this is
kind of like a banker structure
with white where you give up a pawn but
you get
very aggressive play on these open
files on the h and g sometimes you can
even go queen g for
pressing on that g pawn
but in any case emanuel alaska played
queen h6
g3 a6
f4 and that's kind of a tricky maneuver
by tartakover
you might have expected him to go bishop
g2 and then play not f4
anyways but that wasn't really his point
he's just trying to create a very solid
center over there and g3 kind of fits
into that plan
a6 stopping this knight b5 jump
if you would go c5 here there's knight
b5
and you have to deal with these forks
and last but not least
that knight could land on d6 and
something that you wouldn't want to have
so a6 was played f4 c5 and that's
why law school played a6 bishop d3
so the bishop and most of these french
positions belong to d3
because it exerts pressure on h7
you could put it on g2 and it creates
a good defensive setup for your king
but it's not really active and in fact
this
whole construction of d5 e6 f7 is built
against that
bishop d3 g6
and i wonder if you guys can guess
tartakover's next move if you've seen
the last game you might actually realize
that
hey tartakover is an aggressive player
so next move shouldn't be too tough to
find
and a few words about lasker even though
his contemporary said that he wasn't a
sound player
the semislav that you know and the
concept of breaking through
with c5 and b5 on the queen side that
was actually devised
by losker so his methods
are actually very high level and that's
kind of the reason why he was so
competitive even
in his 50s he was
putting up some and posting some good
results
versus the best of the best who could
challenge him
probably recent time anand as someone
who's at
oscar's level and the late viktor
korchnoy of course
both of them anand and korchnoy
is kind of living up to the heritage
of emmanuel oscar and even in this game
you can see
he likes to break through with a6 and c5
however it does take a lot of time and
tartakover takes the initiative goes for
queen f3 what's the point of queen f3
he is going for long castling and
sets up some sacrificial ideas on
d5 note that
even though oscar is up a pawn most of
his pieces are scattered
and there's not much communication going
on with those pieces
again something that you don't want to
do is to play knight e2
early you might want black to commit
if he she is going to go cd or c4
because if you go knight d2 way too
early this is a typical way of losing a
bishop
c4 and there is no
convenient place for the bishop to hide
so queen f3 and that's what tartakover
exactly does
he doesn't really want to show his hands
and he's asking
mr amano alaska where are you going to
put your pawn emanuellas kerr tells him
and takes on d4 knight e2
at c6 now knight takes d5
is probably a little bit premature
because white is not
castled yet and doesn't have enough
forces
to break through with the attack and one
of the key features of
future grand masters and the best of the
past
best of the best in the past
that they would go for sacrifices when
they felt
that they have etiquette play for the
piece
or of a sacrifice so knight d2
knight c6 knight g5 finally with this
queen defending this rook
it's time for some active play queen g7
queen f2 and probably this knight is
trying to waltz back to the game and if
he could take on d4 with a knight that
would be an ideal
french position for tartakover not f3
knight c5 long castles and we actually
have
a similar situation like in the previous
game
black does have a solid position but
desperately lacks
development ship d7
knight d4 long castles
and again here comes the critical point
of the game
you have to figure out what to do
if i look at it i'd say black is doing
okay but so does white white has a
wonderful knight on d4
a good grip over the center and
oscar is oceans away from actually
having that f6 break in
and if there's no f6 breaks that means
that tartar cover
should have the upper hand
however it's one thing to have a static
advantage
meaning you have the control so
everything is looking good
you have more space and you have the
initiative actually you don't really
have the initiative quite yet
you did have some pressure on the h file
but that kind of dis
excuse me dissipated so we have to look
for
a different way to break through
and for that tartakover found this very
nice move of knight takes c6
completely illogical if you would ask
anyone
it's illogical because every exchange
helps your opponent however tartakover
has a plan in mind now you can capture
back
because this pony is hanging on c5
when knight d3 look takes d3 bishop
takes c6
plaque does get into a terrible
formation
that you really don't want to have
black is saddened with a french bishop
and once starter cover gets the knight
to d4
it will have no future at all
but first and foremost tartakover is
going for the attack and goes for queen
a7
making sure the king cannot go to b8
and it is forced into the middle of the
board somewhere around here
king c7 rook b3 immediately
eyeing the king now if white would get
one extra move it would be completely
busted
for loscar because that bishop
once it's eliminated the attack is just
crashing through
and again same thing that he said about
in the previous game
those pieces just don't contribute to
the defenses
d4 d4 is a very strong move by
loscar even though he's
in grave danger and probably lost this
is the most tenacious way of defending
and if you've noticed most of the world
champions are
very good defenders name it lasker
carlson kasparov karpov they're very
good at defending
anytime they see the slightest of
counter chances they will go for it
the reason i extol this move d4 is
because it activates this bishop and at
least
tries to look for some play even though
his king is under heavy fire
queen b6 king c8
rook d1 and that is also a sign
of a strong player tartakover is not
panicking
just brings in another piece and
prepares this idea of knight d4
good or bad i think oscar should have
taken on f3 play rook d7 and
hope he decided to play rook d5 instead
but i'm not a fan
kind of closes that bishop on c6
rook d8 book d5 ship d5
rook c3 king d7
knight d4 and as predicted
once the knight lands on d4 the end is
nigh
queen f8 but queen f8 was already
not such a pretty move that you would
want to play
now it's white to move and get
the final touches
so let's think about this a little bit
now this king is a little bit iffy but
it's still not that easy
to come around it and actually checkmate
that king
on d7
compared to the bishop on c6 which was
blocked by that d5 pawn
this bishop was actually quite useful
defending
the most crucial squares on e6 and
b7
so if you're trying to crash through
quickly
you might want to remove that defender
so the first move obviously is rook c7
check
king e8 sadly enough
no checks if we could give a queen a4
check that would be brilliant
so even an idea of queen a5 queen a4
however
slow is still something that tartakova
could have considered
but he saw a much quicker plan and he
played
c4 instead a brave move in some ways
because
you are exposing your king so if it's
not
a direct win it is somewhat risky
but i'm pretty sure tartakover
calculated this
now the bishop is under danger
we should be e4 and here comes
the decisive blow i take c6
and it is a game over because if f takes
e6
queen takes e6 there is no
way of stopping mate on e7
quite a picturesque end to the game
all of black's pieces are on
the eighth rank except that bishop so at
least that bishop succeeded
in getting out of that miserable square
of c8
however the king got mated
on the middle of the board which is kind
of sad
but checkmate is
checkmate quite a nice game by
tartakover
and what i really enjoyed in this game
is that he was
relentless he started going he gave up a
pawn
but at the end of the day what he was
looking for
is active piece play and making sure
that
that bishop on c6 is smothered
and when it wasn't it was already too
late the knight
jumped in on d4 and there was nothing
that the opponent could do
so that was the
games i wanted to show for you guys
and hope you enjoyed tartakover's
brilliant twins and his recipe against
the french
take care
you